(whipping)
(squeaking)
- [Voiceover] This is a baby.
Basically a human, but
smaller and always drunk.
She has caught the eye of a boy baby.
He has picked out a ball for her.
Now they are having a moment
that will soon be forgotten,
because they're babies.
None of them are sure where they are.
Is it someone's birthday or something?
Oh, it's for a photo shoot,
the world's biggest baby photo shoot.
Seriously? Don't parents have
enough pictures of their kids?
Parents are the worst, am I right?
Here is a baby being fed
lemons by his mother,
so he can see how sour it is.
Look how the mother is
smiling while the baby cries.
You know, it's not actually
that bad outside the womb.
Uh-oh, here's some new
babies to join the fun.
Watch out, this baby pooped
himself and couldn't care less.
This baby is trying to
connect with another baby,
but he felt their relationship
was moving too fast
and now she is alone.
This is when she realized the
Disney movies were all lies.
This baby has found a friend to cry with,
sometimes it helps to have a friend.
Wish I had a friend.
There is a woman touching the babies
and taking their pictures.
The babies seem to have
no say in any of this.
Out of boredom,
these babies have started
their own fight club.
Here's a baby trying
to escape the ball pit,
silly baby, there is no escape.
This prodigy is getting a
head start with Snapchat,
has created a new filter with her mouth.
And another baby afraid of commitment,
that's a bad baby.
Bad babies get fed lemons.
There are so many babies in the room now.
Oh finally, this must mean
it's time to take the picture.
Say cheese little ones!
Cheese!
(picture snaps)
Wait are, are any of the
babies looking at the camera?
What was the whole point of any of this?
In any case, we're gonna
reward them anyway.
Here are some bubbles.
Soothing, calming bubbles.
Aah, oh,
well, I guess it doesn't
work for everyone.
Now here's a montage of babies falling.
(old time piano music)
(whipping)
(squeaking)